à 49,15 alors il n'a pas la majorité
absolue puisqu'il est à 49 c'est moins
de 50 mais il est quand même de ventre
et clairement 49,15 moi j'ai fait 30 et
quelques et Madame Geoffroy et ln
Geoffroy a fait autour de 20 non le
score de 19 malheureusement j'aimerais
beaucoup et nous aimerions beaucoup tous
pouvoir la prouver moi j'ai déjà perdu
des élections à très peu de voix c'était
contraire vue Morin en 2015 en Normandie
et j'avais tout de suite salué la
victoire de Hervé moi le problème que
l'on a là et toute la France l'a vu et
c'est ça qui est malheureux c'est que
notre partie je n'accuse personne en
particulier mais la direction est quand
même responsable nous sommes incapables
d'organiser un scrutin qui donne un
résultat incontestable quelques heures
après la fin la clôture du scrutin alors
que les Verts y arrivent le PC y arrive
les républicains y arrivent les
élections professionnelles ça se fait
par vote électronique que ça fonctionne
bon donc il y a vraiment un souci de ce
côté là maintenant je pense qu'on en est
à la limite plus là c'est à dire que il
y a Marseille le congrès à la fin de la
semaine et moi je dis une chose une
chose simple maintenant il faut que
Olivier Faure prenne ses responsabilités
nous nous avons pris les nôtres et nous
avons fait des propositions
Olivier fort et le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste non je ne peux pas le
dire de la même façon je vais le dire
d'une autre manière que je ne peux pas
non plus une moi revendiquer quoi que ce
soit puisque la commission de
recollement qui est l'instance qui
valide le scrutin n'a pas pu terminer
son travail elle a été empêchée de
terminer son travail et donc toutes les
irrégularités ou les fraudes que j'ai
dénoncé et je continuerai de le faire
parce que je pense que ce sont des
pratiques qui sont datées et qui ne sont
pas conformes à l'idée que nous nous
faisons de la démocratie et bien elles
n'ont pas toutes été examinées et
intégré au scrutin vous savez personne
ne peut s'autoproclamer mais je répète
maintenant notre responsabilité
vis-à-vis des Français c'est de faire
des propositions pour sortir rassemblées
vous dites la commission de récollement
n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout de ses
travaux est-ce que vous demandez est-ce
qu'elle le fasse aujourd'hui oui
j'aimerais beaucoup mais nous le
demandons depuis le départ à vrai dire
nous avons vous le demandez mais vous
semblez le demander un peu moins fort
aujourd'hui qu'hier
je demande simplement que tout le monde
puisse s'appuyer sur un résultat
incontestable mais j'essaie de aussi de
mesurer l'urgence du moment moi j'ai
conscience de la nécessité que les
socialistes puissent être rassemblés
pour les Français l'urgence sociale les
retraites par rapport aux autres
qui étaient sur splato hier il nous dit
mais les résultats ils sont publiés ils
sont consultables ils sont transparents
ils sont au siège du Parti socialiste
vous êtes allés de les consulter
j'imagine qu'est-ce qui ne vous convient
pas une série alors je le répète de
façon posée officiellement c'est pas
vrai non il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments qui n'ont pas été vérifiés
par la Commission de récollement qui en
était à peu près 45 fédérations qui
avaient été validées une quinzaine qui
était ce qu'on appelle réserver
c'est-à-dire en cours d'examen et les
autres qui ne l'était pas et à ce
moment-là des membres de la commission
et de la direction sortante on
considérait qu'il arrêter les travaux il
y a eu un vote alors que les
représentants de montexoration avait
quitté la salle et demander qu'il n'y
ait pas de vote qui est une suspension
de séance et à ce moment-là tout a été
arrêté donc je suis pas en train de
revendiquer une victoire je suis en
train de dire que malheureusement ils
étaient déjà trois quatre jours après le
scrutin c'est ça qui va pas c'est pas
normal qu'on en met un samedi dimanche
quand même franchement pour 24000
votants je rappelle qu'au début du
mandat d'Olivier Faure en 2018 à
Aubervilliers c'est facilement
vérifiable il y avait 39000 votants là
on est à 23500 ça veut dire moins 38% un
peu moins de 40% en moins de votants
c'est quand même pas formidable donc je
ne dis pas que c'est la faute d'Olivier
ou de Pierre Paul Jacques c'est notre
responsabilité collective donc ce que
j'essaye de dire c'est que maintenant là
il y a le Congrès qui arrive dans trois
jours est-ce qu'on veut que ce soit une
réussite ou est-ce qu'on veut que ce
soit une catastrophe une dernière chose
quand même sur le recompte des voix vous
pointez du doigt par exemple ce qui
s'est passé à Liévin ou la police a
demandé les scrutateurs de sortir de la
salle et donc il y a un doute sur le
résultat vous n'avez aucun moyen de
pression auprès d'Olivier fort pour que
c'est votre soient recontés mais je veux
pas vérifier de moyens de pression je
dis simplement que la démocratie devrait
être respectée sur Liévin vous voyez il
y a eu plusieurs irrégularités
manifestes et moi je parle de fraude il
y a eu des bulletins qui étaient dans
l'urne avant même l'ouverture du scrutin
cela aurait été enlevés il y en avait 22
mais au total il y a eu plus de 300 voix
celle là n'ont pas été enlevées alors
qu'il n'y a pas pu y avoir de
vérification ni des cartes d'identité ni
des feuilles d'émargement ni de qui
voter etc etc vous voyez bien que ça va
pas voilà donc tout ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un résultat incontestable en
trois quatre jours il y a vraiment un
gros problème qu'est-ce que vous
demandez qu'est-ce qu'il faut alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui pour
que vous reconnaissez sur résultat c'est
la commission de recollement qui doit se
remettre au travail même si Olivier Ford
dit que si elle avait poursuivi son
travail le résultat sera encore plus
important ou est-ce que vous dites il
faut un nouveau vote voilà le vote je le
reconnais pas il faut à nouveau c'est
intéressant parenthèse vous venez de
dire même Olivier Faure dit si la
Commission avait terminé son travail
avec toutes les irrigateurs alors
j'aurais gagné encore plus bah alors qui
a peur de la démocratie est chiche
allons jusqu'au bout du travail la
Commission et puis moi je serai heureux
de valider et de reconnaître le résultat
si précisément lui-même un irrégularité
dans les bureaux
et je veux dire je ne demande que le
fait que l'on respecte l'ensemble du
scrutin et que la transparence soit
totale si lui-même est persuadé que si
on faisait ça il gagne serait encore
plus gagnant mais alors très bien tant
mieux alors vous demandez pas un nouveau
vote vous demandez juste que la
Commission de se remettre au travail
c'était exactement ce que nous
demandions et ce que nous continuons de
demander maintenant il y a aussi un
moment politique et le moment politique
d'aujourd'hui c'est le congrès de
Marseille c'est l'urgence François
Hollande par exemple lui demande un
nouveau vote pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
le faites pas parce que vous savez que
c'est vous à l'échec ou personne n'y a
intérêt on comprend la proposition de
François Hollande mais la difficulté
c'est que si vous faites un nouveau vote
dans les mêmes conditions alors qu'on
voit que malheureusement notre partie
est incapable d'organiser un scrutin
d'une façon claire et nette avec 24 000
votants la crainte c'est que les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets et si
on fait un nouveau vote il faut que les
conditions de ce nouveau vote soient
meilleurs est-ce qu'il faut à ce
moment-là des huissiers ce qu'il faut
inventer électronique mais tout ça
qui se fait normalement c'est à dire que
la Commission de recollement qui est la
seule instance personne ne devrait
pouvoir s'autoproclamer qui est la seule
instance normalement compétente pour
pouvoir dire voilà le vote incontestable
puisse finir son travail le problème
c'est que maintenant on arrive à
Marseille alors justement sur les
propositions parce qu'effectivement il y
a eu des propositions vous avez demandé
notamment une direction collégiale
temporaire mais collégiale Olivier Faure
vos réponses c'est compliqué diriger à 4
il faut bien quelqu'un qui décide au
final est-ce qu'il a pas un petit peu
raison là-dessus ce qu'on dit tout
simplement d'abord c'est que quand il y
a ces Mitterrand qui disait ça que quand
il y a une volonté il y a un chemin ce
que dire par là c'est est-ce qu'on a
envie de travailler ensemble ou pas
parce que on dit on veut rassembler
ensemble mais pas au même exactement je
m'explique on dit on veut rassembler
toute la gauche
si on n'est pas capable de nous
rassembler nous entre nous socialistes
je suis pas sûr qu'on va être très
crédible pour rassembler toute la gauche
quand même donc là il vous propose donc
il nous semble qu'il est important de
pouvoir se rassembler qu'est-ce qu'on
constate vous avez eu deux votes le 12
le 19 le 19 visiblement c'est très
compliqué et quoi qu'on en dit sur le
score final sur le 19 c'est 49 51 pour
les uns c'est 51 49 pour les autres 12
janvier qui a donné un score qu'il a
pour le coup est reconnu par tout le
monde 49, quelque chose pour Olivier
fort 30 pour moi enfin mon équipe et 20
pour Hélène Geoffroy nous ce qu'on dit
c'est faisons une direction collégiale
qui s'appuie sur ce score là puisqu'il
est incontesté
et qui permettent à chacun d'être dans
ce collège parce qu'on a besoin de
rassembler tout le monde évidemment avec
une fonction particulière peut-être
d'animation par exemple de ce collège
d'Olivier Faure puisqu'il a fait 49
c'est quand même pas la même chose que
30 ou 20 moi j'ai aucun problème à
reconnaître ça évidemment il a proposé
secrétaire adjoint pourquoi ça
ni d'être adjoint ni quoi que ce soit je
dis juste que on a des fonctions qui
sont des fonctions de Premier
secrétariats qui ont d'ailleurs déjà par
le passé pu être assuré par un collège
de direction et donc l'idée c'est de
dire voilà vous avez ces fonctions de
premier secrétariations et donc l'idée
c'est de dire voilà vous avez ces
fonctions de Premier secrétariat
assurons les ensemble avec une
responsabilité particulière pour Olivier
Faure pour animer ce collège si vous
voulez c'est ce qu'on appelle en latin
primus inter paresse on a l'impression
que vous dites exactement la même chose
j'ai fait la proposition je vous le dis
ce matin j'ai sollicité Hélène Geoffroy
et Olivier Faure encore hier soir pour
concevoir aujourd'hui j'espère que je
serai entendu pour concevoir aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut terminer cette affaire
maintenant
pour premier secrétaire adjoint non je
dis pas ok pour promouvoir je dis
travaillons sur cette proposition de
collège de direction qui permettent
aussi à Hélène Geoffroy qui permettent à
l'ensemble des parties de pouvoir
exercer ses responsabilités c'est quoi
la différence entre Olivier Faure qui
dit je propose une direction collégiale
avec un poste de premier secrétaire
adjoint à Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et et
vous qui dites travaillons une
collégialité de
je vois votre question j'essaye d'y
répondre précisément la question c'est
l'égalité de responsabilité sur les
livres
ce sont les fonctions c'est à dire que
mais vous dites vous allez de façon
c'est pas une question de niveau c'est
si vous voulez vous avez différentes
fonctions dans le parti j'avais les
élections par exemple Olivier Faure
j'essaie de le décrire de façon neutre
pour expliciter sa proposition disait
par exemple il pourrait s'occuper plutôt
de l'Europe il a parlé de une question
européenne c'est-à-dire dans cette dans
cette optique là vous avez personne qui
est plutôt sur tel sujet une autre sur
une autre etc moi ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est que on en est pas à
ce stade là du tout et que nous de
revendiquons qu'il puisse y avoir une
égalité des responsabilités dans ce
collège c'est à dire que les fonctions
de Premier secrétariat qui sont
multiples il y a l'Europe mais il y a
aussi le secrétariat aux élections
l'organisation du parti le renouveau
de gérer les élections européennes
pourquoi vous avez refusé je suis maire
de Rouen et que je suis très occupé à
Rouen tout simplement et que je ne
revendique pas de poste et encore une
fois je l'ai déjà dit je pense que
comment dire c'est pas la bonne façon de
faire d'essayer de je dis pas que c'est
ce qu'il a forcément voulu faire mais ça
peut donner l'impression que on essaye
bon ben voilà d'avoir tel poste pour
taloché pour telle personne je crois que
c'est ce qui n'a pas voulu faire Xavier
des inquiétudes sur la ligne et sur le
fait qu'il y aurait une liste du Parti
socialiste aux européennes et que du
coup il vous donne la preuve que ce ne
sera pas le cas il vous laisse la tête
de liste pour bien vous pouvez que ce ne
sera pas le cas pourquoi du coup vous
n'avez pas parce que je ne revendique
certainement pas la tête de liste parce
que je suis bien occupé à Rouen et je
suis très heureux d'être mère de Rouen
et parce que je pense que ça n'est pas
la bonne façon de faire on ne se
répartit pas les postes les Français
attendent autre chose d'un grand parti
politique que je te donne si tu me
donnes ça c'est tout ce que je veux dire
donc vous voyez que c'est pas la même
philosophie moi ce que je propose c'est
vraiment de manifester d'envoyer le
message excusez-moi juste pour terminer
que on travaille ensemble et je dis ce
matin Olivier Faure maintenant il est
temps qu'il prenne ses responsabilités
s'il veut vraiment participer comme nous
le faisons aujourd'hui au rassemblement
de toute la gauche et des socialistes
alors maintenant il faut prendre ses
responsables
vous vous nous dites juste une petite
précision je vous en parle vous nous
dites j'ai appelé Olivier Faure je lui
ai proposé concevoir aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui vous a répondu
il me dit on va voir il faut qu'on ait
avancé etc moi j'ai fait une proposition
sur la table je pense qu'il faut
concevoir aujourd'hui voilà j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir se voir aujourd'hui
juste un petit pas en arrière est-ce que
ce qui est en jeu c'est pas les
investitures aux différentes élections
européennes municipales législatives
est-ce que c'est pas la nuque au fond
qui est en jeu derrière ces divergences
est-ce que vous voudriez pas présenter
des candidats socialistes lors de ces
élections alors qu'Olivier Faure
voudrait garder la main pour pouvoir
présenter des candidats variés alors
très factuellement nous n'avons pas
parlé d'investiture à l'exception de
cette affaire européenne mais ce que je
peux dire en revanche c'est que sur le
fond depuis le début de cette campagne
effectivement de notre côté nous portons
cette idée que nous voulons défendre des
candidatures socialistes avec
éventuellement des partenaires qui nous
rejoignent sur le fond sur les valeurs
vous voyez par exemple sur l'Europe on
voit bien qu'avec la France insoumise je
respecte leur position mais il y a des
positions qui sont extrêmement
différentes c'est pas de de degrés c'est
la nature sur les questions européennes
et donc il faut qu'on soit cohérent
vis-à-vis des Français si vous intégriez
cette direction collégiale est-ce que
vous demanderiez clairement est-ce que
le PS sort de la nuque non parce que je
l'ai dit pendant la campagne la Nupe
aujourd'hui n'est rien d'autre que un
intergroupe à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire que les différents
parlementaires travaillent ensemble à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est utile et
a fortiori quand il y a par exemple la
question des retraites sur la table en
revanche nous disons bon j'ai utilisé
cette formule souvent alliée oui aligner
non nous disons que quand il y a des
sujets où nous devons avoir des
positions différentes parce que le Parti
socialiste a des positions différentes
mais il faut les affirmer comme le font
d'ailleurs le PC avec Fabien Roussel ou
élevé les verts avec Marine Tondelier
Mariton de lier sur l'Europe elle dit on
n'a pas les mêmes positions donc on va
pas faire une liste nups parce que on
n'a pas les mêmes positions
c'est effectivement un sujet important
pour les sociétés puisqu'il y a beaucoup
de communes qui sont gérées par des
d'ailleurs des rassemblements de la
gauche mais souvent dirigé par des nous
nous disons que les sortants socialistes
quand ils n'ont pas démérités s'ils le
souhaitent doivent pouvoir être
il peut y avoir un doute si on dit la
Nupe ce jusqu'au bout ça veut dire quoi
pour les municipales
je sais pas si c'est un danger parce
qu'on n'est pas adversaire on est
concurrent à gauche sur ce genre
d'élection mais ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est que il faut quand même faire
crédit c'est un problème quand même dans
le Parti socialiste aujourd'hui il faut
quand même faire crédit au territoire
aux élus locaux aux militants dans les
territoires qui n'ont pas démérités qui
travaillent depuis longtemps qui font de
belles réalisations qui quand ils sont
dans les minorités se battent aussi
depuis longtemps contre la droite ou
l'extrême droite et moi comme premier
secrétaire ou comme participant à une
direction collégiale j'entends bien
qu'il soit défendu mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas en train avec ces divisions
et avec l'image que vous renvoyez ces
derniers jours du Parti socialiste
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
l'affaiblir au sein de la nuque alors
que vous voulez en faire un moteur mais
vous savez c'est toujours le dilemme
dans ces cas-là mais j'essaye de d'agir
en conscience et une conscience à la
fois de militance socialiste mais aussi
de citoyens et de mer
quand il y a des fraudes je ne vais pas
me taire je suis désolé de le dire comme
cela parce que les fraudes ne sont pas
systématiques partout il y a évidemment
plein d'endroit où ça s'est passé très
bien et c'est heureusement la majorité
mais il y a des situations et
franchement sans langue de bois beaucoup
de socialisme le savent très bien et
depuis longtemps et je vais aller plus
loin ça peut être même été pire par le
passé et je ne suis pas en train de dire
que c'est la faute de Olivier fort en
lui-même mais il est à la tête de notre
famille politique depuis 5 ans si vous
reprenez des déclarations d'Olivier à
Aubervilliers ou ensuite on devait par
exemple mettre en place le vote
électronique comme l’ont fait plein de
parties peut-être que ça aurait concouru
à garantir un scrutin plus sincère ça
n'a pas été fait je dis pas que c'est
facile à faire il peut ça peut être
difficile enfin d'autres l'ont fait
quand même et nous on y arrive pas c'est
pas normal et donc quand il y a des
fraudes je suis désolé mais moi
j'organise des élections par ailleurs
comme mère je ne peux pas les accepter
et donc je ne peux pas ne rien dire
maintenant je suis aussi un responsable
politique et là dans ce moment politique
je dis à Olivier Faure et à tous ses
amis parce qu'on a beaucoup d'amis en
commun et heureusement maintenant il
faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités nous on fait une
proposition pour que tout le monde soit
respecté il faut pas qu'il y ait
d'humiliation et le score qui est
incontestable c'est celui du 12 janvier
appuyons-nous dessus et on va trouver
une solution ensemble à condition
qu'effectivement il y a un vrai collège
et pas si j'ose dire une école
maternelle si vous me permettez cette
formule c'est un collège un collège
c'est un collège de responsabilité à
égalité de responsabilité il peut y
avoir quelqu'un qui est un primus inter
paresse comme on dit et ça serait
logique quand on regarde le score du 12
janvier mais un collège c'est un collège
alors la commission de recueillement ne
va pas aller visiblement au bout de ses
travaux avant le congrès de Marseille
vous avez du mal à trouver vous avez du
mal à trouver une solution concernant
cette direction collégiale est-ce que
dans ces conditions le congrès de
Marseille peut se tenir est-ce qu'il y a
pas un risque de débordement de dérapage
et
je vais pas vous faire de langue de bois
évidemment qu'il y a un risque ça c'est
sûr puisque clairement vous avez vu que
il y a de la tension
et qu'il y a un risque aussi de fracture
et que ce parti s'est déjà fracturé à
plusieurs reprises maintenant je ne le
souhaite absolument pas et je fais tout
pour que avant Marseille on trouve un
accord ok est-ce qu'un risque la réponse
ce serait malhonnête vraiment de dire
suggéré en ajournement de ce congrès
est-ce que vous le souhaitez est-ce
qu'il est possible statutairement tout
est possible mais mais
bon moi je préférerais si vous me
demandez mon avis je préférerais que on
trouve une voie de sortie politique
j'essaye de me d'être positif et de me
focaliser sur le moment politique les
Français nous attendent il y a une
urgence sociale sur beaucoup de sujets
retraites pouvoir d'achat et bien
d'autres le Parti socialiste que nous
souhaitons qu'il soit au cœur de la
gauche ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'il
sorte de cette crise le plus vite besoin
si la situation reste telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui vous irez à Marseille
j'espère qu'elle va pas empirer parce
que ce serait quand même dommage
aujourd'hui je vais à Marseille bien
entendu
est-ce qu'il y aura une image de vous
deux tout dépend si on arrive à trouver
un accord et je le souhaite vous voyez
nous avons fait des propositions
maintenant c'est à Olivier Faure de
prendre ses responsabilités enfin quand
même s'il souhaite demain exercer des
fonctions
de première ampleur et il est tout à
fait légitime pour les revendiquer
évidemment pour notre partie il doit
quand même concourir à rassembler nous
on prend nos responsabilités voilà nos
propositions voilà comment on peut
travailler ensemble ça c'est déjà fait
c'est possible maintenant à lui d'être à
la hauteur du moment Benoît Paillon qui
n'est plus au PS mais qui était encore
très récemment a dit s'il n'y a pas
d'accord d'ici vendredi je veux pas que
le Congrès se tienne dans ma ville
est-ce que vous comprenez ça oui je le
comprends très bien je le comprends
Benoît paillant qui est un excellent
merde de Marseille se bat pour sa ville
dynamique de sa ville le rayonnement de
sa ville la réputation de sa ville je
comprends très bien pour le dire d'une
phrase que il est pas envie que la
réputation de sa ville soit associée un
congrès qui se passerait mal donc
effectivement je le comprends très bien
mais soyons responsables de notre côté
c'est le sens de nos propositions pour
que on ait une sortie par le haut avant
Marseille si on arrive à Marseille et
qui a pas d'accord effectivement c'est
une recette pour que ça se passe mal oui
est-ce que vous avez changé avec
François Hollande ces derniers jours
depuis ce qui se passe il ne vous donne
aucun conseil ne vous dit rien il ne
vous demande rien question simple
réponse
qu'aujourd'hui vous craignez une
scission du PS est-ce que c'est dans les
têtes de tout le monde mais
là encore je ne le souhaite absolument
pas pour ma part je suis socialiste je
resterai socialiste
mais aujourd'hui ça semble probable la
vérité c'est que ce parti est allé de
division alors on appelle ça division
aussi si on comme vous voulez mais de
division en division depuis des années
je vous ai dit Aubervilliers 39000
votants aujourd'hui moins 40%, mais même
avant Olivier Faure il y avait déjà des
départs et des départs un le fameux
étant fraction Monsieur Mélenchon en
2008 plus récemment monsieur Cazeneuve
et beaucoup d'autres Emmanuel Macron
éviter ça parce que les Français
attendent ça c'est quand même un point
important si on prend un peu de recul
les Français attendent une offre de
gauche qui manque aujourd'hui qui est
une offre de gauche réellement à gauche
qui parle au rassemblement et qui porte
le rassemblement de la gauche mais
réellement crédible et cette offre-là
elle manque aujourd'hui nous c'est ce
que nous portons clairement si vous
arrivez sans accord au congrès à
Marseille Olivier fort sera réélu
premier secrétaire est-ce que dans ces
conditions vous restez au PS ou vous
essayez de reconstruire quelque chose
par exemple autour de Bernard Cazeneuve
non je ne veux pas du tout me placer
dans cette optique là aujourd'hui parce
que
si vous voulez ce serait vécu par grosso
modo la moitié des militants qui ont
voté puisque c'est ça le résultat du 19
comme une humiliation une imposition une
sorte de coup de force ce serait
terrible quelle que soit les enjeux
juridiques ou administrats
politiquesment ce serait catastrophique
tout le monde le comprend bien si on est
à moitié-moitié il faut rassembler pas
diviser merci Nicolas meilleur signal
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
invité la Une de La Dépêche énergie le
bouclier sera-t-il suffisant c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci Christelle
merci beaucoup pour ce club des
territoires